the first question I wanted to ask you
the book is called high-growth handbook
not not the high-growth hanjo just
high-growth handbook given that so few
companies ever make it to high-growth
you know thousands of employees why
should an average entrepreneur read this
book yeah I think the book contains some
more universal principles so things like
how do you go about hiring people in
what should you look for when you hire
people including executives how do you
you know if somebody's trying to buy
your company you may actually want to
read the section on M&A because it'll
basically reveal how the company that's
trying to buy you is actually thinking
about it and there's also product
management best practices in there and
how do you think about product
management so I do think that there's a
variety of other sections there's also a
section on PR comms and marketing so you
know what's the difference between those
just different disciplines and how
should you think about them so I do
think that there are areas of the book
that touch upon the things that are
universal but ultimately it was geared
for either employees who are going
through high growth or executives or
founders who are going through high
growth and in part simply because there
wasn't any information out there in my
opinion that was really pulled together
and codified around that yeah and what
inspired you to shift this into a book
rather than you know your own personal
blog site you know SEO targeted sure
content yeah I resume was thinking of
doing it as a website and John Collison
one of the cofounders of stripe saw the
the content and got excited about it and
thought it would be really relevant to
to both other founders who are working
on high growth but also sort of the
broader community of developers and
company builders that stripe serves and
so that led to the genesis of strike
publishing it okay gotcha I have a
question about before even page one
maybe it is counted as a page the
dedication I was just curious what you
met so the first line is to my lovely
wife Jennifer and suddenly of suddenly
everything is possible again what does
that mean there's a great book from
Jonathan Safran for called
I think it's called the eating animals
okay and it's about it's sort of a mixed
book but it talks a little bit about his
own son and he says that when he
kid somebody sent him a card that said
suddenly everything is possible again
about his son and really what that means
is when you look at your child you
realize that every possibility is
suddenly ahead of them and there's a
reinvention of life through that child
in other words they could go and become
an Olympic skater they could you know
become the next Mark Zuckerberg or they
could have a terrible life but really
all the possibilities in the world in
some sense are available to them and so
that's really what that means and do you
take it to heart for you as well I'm too
old for that so I think the next
generation has everything is possible
for them okay barring some breakthrough
in anti-aging or something I think my
path is reasonably clear all right fine
so with all of these interviews did I
know they were edited and kind of
they're transcribed and then edited
were there any large arguments you got
into when you're doing the interviews
before you compiled them for the book
there's no arguments and the interviews
are actually very close to the actual
conversations so the editing was very
light and it was more for clarity or to
rearrange a section so it went together
better but there weren't big Chuck
chunks taken out unless it was a side
conversation that was unrelated to the
interview there are areas where I've
disagreed with some of the things that
people said and that's one of the
reasons I wanted to make sure it was in
the book yeah because ultimately I think
the only good generic startup advice is
that there's no good generic startup
advice and ultimately it's all about
context and each person who I
interviewed came from a very different
set of experiences a very different
context and that's one of the reasons I
wanted to include those discussions in
the book as they provided a different
viewpoint from my own mm-hmm what are
good examples of that honestly almost
every interview there may have been like
one or two things that I would have
nitpicked and I'm sure that as people
read my book they'll feel the same way
or they're like well in my case it
really wasn't like that or you know the
advice I give is a little bit different
from that and I think that's actually
great you know there it's almost like
you're baking a cake and you can get
into a philosophical argument about the
right way to bake a cake and when all is
said and done there's a few core
components you always need when making a
cake but there's lots of different ways
to do it and I think that's true of
startups as well there's a few
fundamental things you absolutely have
to do otherwise it's not really a cake
or not a start-up but besides that you
know go at it there's all sorts of ways
to do things mm-hmm yeah I was um I was
rewatching your investor school talk
this morning and you were talking about
how you pick companies based on market
and then market again and then the third
was maybe team yeah yeah yeah yeah do
you find that I think you got into a
Marc Andreessen a little bit in the same
topic right and what he said I found was
interesting he said the companies that
charge more tend to grow faster mm-hmm
do you believe that too I think if you
can get away with charging more than it
means that you have a product that
people truly want it means that you can
grow faster in part because people truly
want your product and in part because
the capital leverage that Marc talks
about is actually crucial in other words
and he makes this point I think really
well on the book which is that if you
have higher margins or pricing power you
can reinvest that money in hiring
additional engineers
your sales team can actually afford to
go and sell or whatever customer
acquisition method you have you can
scale it up more because you have more
margin to give away so actually being
able to raise prices is a very powerful
tool for growth mmm and I think one of
the big fallacies in Silicon Valley is
everybody thinks with their Amazon and
they basically say every business model
should be Amazon's which is I'm gonna
charge as low of a price as possible so
I can get as much market share as
possible and actually it's possible that
you'd get to more market share if you
charged more for your products versus
less so I you know that's actually a
point that I agreed with him quite
strongly right and it's also that you
talked about this in relation to
investing or not investing in lyft that
not all markets are winner-take-all
Amazon type situations yeah exactly I
think yeah most founders assume with any
network effect they win yeah I think
that in general there's a set of myths
that have built up over time in Silicon
Valley around what is a great startup
yeah and in the social networking era
things really were winner-take-all
because they were social networks in the
moments definitionally they were
winner-take-all
and there's lots and lots and lots of
businesses all over the world that
exists in markets that are
winner-take-all and there's actually a
great book called the rule of three I
think is what it's called and it
basically talks about how many
industries collapse into oligopoly
markets where there's two to three
dominant companies and then that's the
stable point in the industry and so I
think the market structure really
matters and one of the things that
people in Silicon Valley don't think
about very much
is what's the actual market structure
and does that mean it's a good
opportunity or a bad opportunity to
actually start a company and a great
example would be EdTech where I think
that's a terrible market it's a really
tough one it's very impactful so I'm
really glad that people are working on
it yeah
but there's all sorts of structural
issues in the market that make it a
really hard one to be successful in and
therefore it's really hard to start a
company in that market mmm-hmm yeah
there was a related question that came
in from Twitter
Leon Koh asked what types of businesses
do you and avoid investing in and what
quote good businesses do you have no
interest in are there other markets that
you have a negative signal to you in
that way yeah EdTech is definitely one
so you know I've never invested in a net
tech company and again I think the
social impact is massive I just think
it's very hard to succeed in part
because there's nobody who is able or
willing to pay in the US for the product
I think in certain parts of Asia
actually a tech is a great market to be
in but I just don't invest very much
outside of the US but if you think about
it
teachers either can't afford or you know
don't have the wherewithal to buy
certain products parents often don't
want to actually buy extra products for
their kids children obviously can't
afford it school districts are often
cash-strapped and can't afford it and so
there's just not a payer in the
education market you know I think
there's also markets where it's better
for a large incumbent to do it versus a
small startup so Internet of Things is a
great example where I think most of the
interesting things in that market will
come from large electronics players who
can just integrate it into something and
then distribute it versus a news for a
one-off company that's just making a
smart light bulb or just making a smart
go block or just making a smart you know
you name it yeah I think those companies
are really struggled after their first
Kickstarter like to launch again I mean
yeah it seems like unless you're selling
like a smart backpack you can't have
time exactly yeah
so you mentioned Asia and I want to jump
from the beginning to the very end of
your book because I thought that was
funny you have a page that says things -
just say no - and I'll go through that
list but I do want to talk about Asia 1
envelopes full of cash - China through
three giant chrome pandas and four
pool tables could you explain oh yeah
that part was very much meant as a joke
and it was kind of thrown in last minute
so basically you know as I've been in
Silicon Valley for the last decade plus
there have been a variety of different
things that seem like great ideas at the
time and then in hindsight maybe weren't
as good and so the envelopes full of
cash for example when I was at Google at
Christmastime the company used to give
out literally an envelope with I think
it was ten hundred dollar bills as sort
of the annual bonus for everybody and
the urban myth around it I don't know
that it was actually true but the urban
myth was that as people would get off
the Google shuttle or the bus in San
Francisco with their envelope full of
cash to get mugged
I don't think I really happened but it
was more you know maybe distributing
millions of dollars in cash is a bad
idea
yeah I'm tearing sounds almost like the
mob or something China is just most
companies that have tried to enter the
China market have failed
there's always counter examples of that
I actually think her strategy in China
was quite smart in terms of their
eventual merger with didi and I think
they owned 15 to 20 percent of didi
which in and of itself is gonna be a
hundred billion dollar plus company so
actually I think that worked out really
well for them and similarly Airbnb
appears to be doing very well in China
as well so I do think it can be done but
most companies try to enter China they
don't have a real strategy to it they
don't understand the the look the the
local presence they don't understand the
competition and they they kind of get
quashed and it's hard to do business
there in part because of government
controls around the ability for foreign
countries to enter the market I'm so
that's China the chrome pandas you know
Dropbox might have giant chrome panda
and then later they used it as a symbol
for frugality and so that I think that
was a very smart approach by them to
basically say hey let's take something
and turn it into a symbol of how we
should act as a company so I thought
that was a very smart cultural move by
them and then lastly pool tables was I
moved out here right after the last sort
of bubble collapsed and I was working at
the startup where I joined it 120 people
and it grew to 160 and then it shrank to
15 people or so after five rounds of
layoffs and so after the second round of
layoffs it was probably like 60 70
people and the founders bought a pool
table to try and increase morale
after all these layoffs were happening
in a collapsing industry and I don't
know that pool tables how you increase
morale but you know that's what they
decide to do and it was it was a nice
gesture but what would happen is the
people who had time to play pool
obviously we're an essential of the
operations of a company that was in
freefall which meant that the people who
play pool would suddenly disappear
within a couple weeks because I get laid
off and so the pool table became the
symbol of like don't go play pool
because you're gonna be the next person
tired yeah okay I have never lived
through one of those but it sounds
terrible I don't think anybody in
Silicon Valley in this era has because
we've been in an eight-year bull market
yeah so obviously companies have gone
under and that's been painful but we
haven't seen the systemic raising of an
entire sector at once and it's
inevitable that at some point that'll
happen again and I think that will cause
an enormous sea change in terms of how
people do things yeah
timing the market is impossible though
related to that are there any ideas
right now that you think might the
raising they're being raised on but are
potentially too early in other words
like ideas from the 99 2001 like bubble
that later turned into big companies now
do you think any of those ideas in
existence now are actually going to be
part of the next cycle I think there's
there's two big areas where that's
definitely true one is AR VR which I
think most of it is too early and I do
think it will eventually happen so yeah
I think the other area is actually in
crypto so I actually think there's a
great analogy between the cryptocurrency
world today and the internet world in
the late 90s and in the late 90s there
was a handful of things that truly
became massive franchises right PayPal
and Google and Amazon and etc were all
from that first era and then there was a
bunch of stuff that didn't even exist at
that point that became massive like
Facebook but there also a lot of
companies that people started then that
ended up failing and were pointed out as
these stupid ideas but are now actually
giant companies in their own right so
for example Webvan raised over a billion
dollars and failed and now we have
instacart which is sort of a reinvention
of that concept there was pets.com which
was broadly derided you know why would
you ship pet food online and that became
chewy which was acquired for I think
three billion dollars and so there
was this whole wave of companies that
were just too early or in the wrong
format in the late 90s that have now
become major franchises and I think the
same thing is true in the crypto world
where there's still a real lack of
infrastructure in crypto and so there's
all sorts of really interesting ideas of
how you decentralize different services
and I think many of those things will
fail and then in 10-15 years a new form
of that idea will exist and be
successful and then in parallel I think
there's things that exist today that are
sort of the Amazon's of crypto that are
going to be massive in their own right
and already exists you know maybe it's
Bitcoin maybe it's at the rim maybe it's
the privacy token like money rosy cash
yeah but I do think that a subset of the
of the crypto world from today will also
continue to just be massive yeah in a
certain percentage of people out there
as employees will be able to pick those
companies yeah which is a dustman of all
quote I really liked I don't know if it
was in the first or the second interview
it must be the second it's on page 311
navall says an evolve Rafa Kahn the most
successful class of people in Silicon
Valley on a consistent basis are either
venture capitalist or people are very
good at identifying companies that have
just hit product market fit they have
the background expertise in references
that those companies really want to help
them scale and I think the question is
how do you find those companies yeah I
think there's a few signals that a
company is breaking out and the point of
the quote from Anibal there's a few
people have been very good at that for
example Matt Kohler was early at
LinkedIn and then he was at Facebook and
then of course he eventually joined
benchmark but that's a great example of
a career where somebody just sort of
identified a few sequential really
interesting things I think the three key
signs of something really breaking out
it really has to do with number one just
anecdotal customer traction so you can
just ask people what they're using if
different companies or you can you know
try to pick up on market signals and so
one is just what is being adopted by the
market and how rapidly is it being
adopted and there's certain metrics you
can look at in terms of turn and
recurrence and a few other things the
second thing is what's the network of
people around it so you know in general
you're only able to pull in certain
people to help with something if that
is really working yeah and then lastly
you know sometimes fundraising as a
signal sometimes it's not but in general
the best companies that are breaking out
if they want the capital or they need
the capital will be fun we'll be raising
new rounds of capital every 9 to 18
months yeah and that's in some cases
given by the fact that we're running out
of money but for the best companies it's
often a sign of people just coming and
preemptively and giving them a very high
valuation so sometimes that's a way to
track it too in general if you want to
do best from a career perspective and
you didn't join in the very very early
days the best time to join is when a
company is probably on the order of 40
50 people and is worth you know
somewhere between 50 and 500 million
dollars as long as it can turn into a 10
20 billion dollar company and it's
really hard to know which company will
do that but usually that's when a
company goes from 50 people to a
thousand people or 50 people to 5,000
people and that's when you have the most
growth opportunities as somebody joining
one of those companies but also you have
the biggest financial upside because
your option package will go up in value
between twenty and a hundred x which can
be quite significant mhm
yeah would you be willing to call
someone out and say what are those
companies right now it's always hard to
know exactly which companies are gonna
be the biggest I think some that are
really promising right now our air table
checker in front in terms of three
companies that I'm involved with that I
just think are you know amazing founders
great traction and doing really
interesting things yeah I see okay so we
should talk about best practices a
little bit we don't want to just talk
about founder mistakes one thing I
really thought was cool which I hadn't
heard about before was stripe CEO Oh
Clare used Johnson issued this letter
out to the company when she started
about how to work well with her I'm
curious what have you done this before
do other people do it now what's a story
yeah I haven't done it before when she
told me about it I thought it was
brilliant and you know each person as
they join a company especially if
they're in a leadership role will have a
certain set of ways that they like to be
interacted with and often it takes the
company six months or twelve months or a
year or longer to figure it out and
especially if you're growing really fast
each incremental hire two years later
has to figure it out as well and so by
publishing this letter she basically
spell
so what are the best ways to work with
her is it better to send her emails or
to cut your life for five minutes is it
better to communicate via data or you
know there are other mechanisms that
really resonate with her in terms of the
things that grab her attention and so I
thought that was just a brilliant
onboarding tool that perhaps any
executive joining a high-growth company
or any manager joining a high-growth
company should issue so that people just
understand this is the fastest best way
to interact with me and just you know
ramped up on on how to be effective in
the organization what I think everyone
should do it at every company yeah I
think it's such a great idea it's like
you can't well it's not totally fair to
rely on everyone to be able to read
everyone else because some people can
just put on a good face yeah and others
can't and some struggle and also people
have their own quirks and so I think
being explicit about the quirk actually
helps a lot like when I worked at
Twitter I used to do a lot of yoga
inside I literally sit in Lotus on the
floor in the middle of executive team
meetings and I was I was the only person
on the floor in board meetings and the
new people event you were like okay fine
that's his quirk right yes so I just
think like being upfront about those
actually gets rid of a bunch of stuff
yeah I think it's such a great idea all
right let's go into some Twitter
questions for you
Massoud Hussain asks he actually has
three questions
how did most of the companies you
interview get their first ten customers
and then from there okay sure first ten
differs a lot by company and so some
companies will literally go and just
hand recruit those first ten people to
use their product and you know the
founders are stripe were famous for
anytime they'd meet with somebody they'd
try and show them stripe and get them to
use it the collison install yeah the
Callisto there's other companies where
honestly they just put up a product
online and it just starts working and
spreading yeah and so I think you know
that's sort of the the rumor about how
Facebook got started was luck just kind
of put it up and told his friends about
it to start spreading because there's a
bit more of a reality built into it so I
think each product is different on
average though you kind of have to grind
it out you have to find your first few
customers if you're building an
enterprise focused application you
probably want to find early test
customers or partners that you work with
who are what people call design partners
so they'll give you feedback as you
build it and you can kind of steer the
product based on their feedbacks you're
actually building something that people
want so it really depends a lot on on
the type of product it is is a consumer
versus enterprise and then how you want
to go about getting the first few people
yeah and what about what about going to
a thousand because Massoud asked a
question related like is content really
King meaning is content the way for like
infinite growth I'm not always it
depends on what you're doing if you're
building a consumer social product then
there's probably mechanics built into
the product itself that cause it to
spread so sometimes things spread a bit
organically and then you kind of juice
it through different tactics so with
Facebook that was email scrapers and it
was you know they were literally running
ads against people's names in Europe to
try and acquire European users for
example so I think the best companies
actually focus on aggressive
distribution early and often you see a
company that taps out and market cap or
market size because the founders weren't
aggressive or early about distribution
and then later other companies caught up
to them mm-hmm and so examples where
people were very aggressive about
distribution with things like Google
where they were spending hundreds of
millions of dollars a year on things
like Firefox having Google prominently
displayed on its homepage they literally
paid for they used to have this client
application called their tool bar that
would you know install against a browser
in terms of being you know effectively
like a browser client and they were
paying hundreds of mainz of dollars a
year to Cohen stall that with different
apps that you download so you download
Adobe and suddenly you'd install the
Google toolbar yeah and those stories
are never told people always say oh
these things just grew organically and
is in an amazing but almost every
company that's ended up and you know
tens of billions or hundred hundreds of
billions in market cap had been very
aggressive about distribution often from
the earliest days and I think a lot of
people create in the content category
they're often playing the game that
whatever system they're on wants them to
play and and that's good to a point but
you're like it's hard to achieve outside
rewards in any of these categories by
just playing by like the exact rules I'm
not saying like break the rules but be a
little more creative with your strategy
all right next question
Mary Ann mala / asks
we're the founders make the most
mistakes is it on hiring and whatever
mistake that might be what steps should
they avoid to avoid these pitfalls yeah
it depends a lot on the stage of a
company you know for an early company
people make mistakes around how much
money to raise they raise too little and
they run out of cash before they can hit
a milestone to raise more money
it could be hiring mistakes it could be
firing with it it could be fighting with
their co-founder so you know early on I
think there's all sorts of mistakes you
can make I think the the single biggest
common issue - the point of the question
probably is around hiring either in
terms of not having a very good
selection process or alternatively not
getting letting go of people who didn't
work out and so there's an old saying
that people either hire well or fire
well and you if you at least do one of
those then you can build a really good
organization
you know fundamentally most companies
are kind of bad at both and that really
ends up biting them because they're just
desperate to get people and instead of
saying you know what is painful but
we'll wait right to find the right
people right it's the company who has a
thousand people and you're like wait a
second can are we like 500 jobs right
now yeah yeah I think it's tough do you
have a do you have like a ballpark
number for how many employees end up
working out percentage-wise
it varies a lot again it depends on your
hiring practices and so Google was an
example of a company that hired
extremely well they had I think it was a
minimum for a while of eight interviews
per person literally and if you didn't
do all the eight you wouldn't be able to
get in kind of thing and they were
terrible at firing in the early day so
they were they were absolutely awful at
letting people go once they made it in
but they just let in so few bad people
that it worked for them for a while
other companies like Facebook were known
as not as good at hiring early on
although they gotten much better over
time but in the very early days they
were known as not great at hiring but
they were very good at actually letting
people go if they didn't work out and so
both companies ended up I think
eventually did very good spots and so I
think it really depends on the the
practices of the company okay
Breann Kimball Kimmel asked a question
around regulation so you both work you
have work with stripe like biotech
you're kind of aware of these regulated
sectors what are some lessons learned in
highly regulated sectors
when should you hire a general counsel
counsel for example and how do you
prioritize public policy in lobbying
efforts I think it depends a lot on the
sector that you're in so some companies
will actually hire a compliance person
or a general counsel very early when
base is an example of that where they
hired somebody of that profile I think
in the first ten people or so and so
they were always focused on being
regulatory compliant you can also do it
through hiring things like external
consultants or you can get very good
lawyers for certain areas so for example
and the biotech or healthcare or sphere
if your six scientists working on a
problem you probably don't need a
full-time compliance person but you
probably want to start thinking about
FDA and you know how you think about
regulations and so that could be done
through a consultant for example so I
think you should think about it early
but it shouldn't get in the way of you
just doing core things that you need to
build a product because if you don't
have a product and you're not on the
market it really doesn't matter you know
because you're not dealing with
regulations as a non launch thing yeah
in terms of prioritizing public policy
and lobbying I think that tends to come
later in the life of a company many
companies in Silicon Valley wait way too
long so they'll they'll sort of become
huge and then they'll realize in
hindsight they should have been thinking
about it and really what it's about is a
view of less as you know lobbying and
more about how can you educate people
who are actually who want to do the
right thing but may only get one side of
the story
if the incumbents are the only ones
talking to them so how do you sort of
share the story of what the industry is
evolving to what the company is about
and who should you be educating and that
doesn't necessarily mean you should be
talking to politicians or maybe other
stakeholders you should be talking to
maybe you should be talking to certain
medical groups if you're in biotech or a
teacher's Association if you're an
EdTech so I would just think more
broadly about who should I educate about
what what I might do it what I'm doing
and how do I start those conversations
or early so that people are aware and in
some cases can actually become
supportive and cinnamon tagging istic
mm-hmm do you have opinions on the ad
campaigns Facebook's running right now
to kind of like say hey we're sorry and
we're not about fake news I haven't seen
those ads I kind of a couple people told
me about him they said that Silicon
Valley is sort of running all these
apologetic at campaigner and multiple so
Wells Fargo Facebook and I think there's
another one yeah you know over you know
one thing that I think has really
changed a lot since I moved out here is
there's been a real decrease and overall
what I call like optimism about the
future in Silicon Valley and I think
that's awful I think really the best
people that I know who work in
technology are doing it because they
think they can use it truly as a force
for good and to help change the world
for the better
and if you think about what technology
is done in terms of basically putting a
supercomputer in the pocket of a billion
plus people in terms of creating
transparency into pricing and markets
and other things for a farmer somewhere
are you able to sell your goods on the
right day at the right location you know
it's really sort of transformed the
world in really positive ways and
somehow I feel that people have really
lost sight of it and to me one of the
saddest moments is when people write the
blog post four years after leaving a
company that they joined early where
they sell flagellate and they talk about
how terrible that company is and how a
shame they are and you're like oh my god
what are you talking about you know
these companies have actually done
really valuable things for the world and
when they've made mistakes they need to
go and correct those mistakes rapidly
and you know they you need to early on
think about how you avoid creating
damage in the world but I think
fundamentally technology is something
that's very powerful very important and
ultimately has largely been a force for
good in the world and we should not lose
sight of that and we should really
emphasize it because you know if you
don't think you're doing great things
you're not gonna go and do great things
no but being here I'm more optimistic
than ever there are so many cool things
happening it's just tricky I mean I know
it from talking to my family on the East
Coast who isn't you know connected in
the same way and all they hear horror
stories from you know whatever it might
be yeah I think in general what you find
and this is I've seen on the company
level when you work with different
companies they always end up in some
media cycle where they get built up and
then they get torn down and then later
they get built up again is sort of a
redemption story so usually the story
arc is look at this amazing company
they're changing the world they're doing
good things and then there's some minor
crisis and it blows up in the press and
- oh my god these company this company's
now doing bad things and they're failing
and they're gonna they're gonna die and
it's awful and
and the press writes a story a little
bit later about oh the company's never
redeemed and they've changed what
they're doing and look at the great
things were doing again and I think that
Silicon Valley may be in one of those
cycles at a macro level where we had the
upswing and the to thousands of oh look
tech is so great and there's the iPhone
and all these other things and look at
how Google is helping people and now
we're in sort of oh my gosh Tech is only
bad and my hope is that we come back
into the redemption period yeah I I
think technology is probably going to be
whipped a little bit more in the next
election cycle because it's like a very
obvious target it seems unfortunately
especially when people are making such
cool stuff yeah I know it's I think one
of the most telling moments for me was a
founder that I've been helped I started
helping really early pinged me and said
hey I was at some dinner party with some
friends and I brought up the fact that
I'm really excited about what I'm doing
and I hope I didn't change the world
with it and everybody started making fun
of me at the dinner and I said well you
should find better friends
you know like ultimately you should be
surrounding yourself with differing
opinions over time but you should also
be surrounding yourself with positive
voices because ultimately I do think
that there's a lot left to be done and
technology will continue to have this
transformative impact on the world and
people should be proud of what they're
working on yeah yeah I mean I'm all for
talking [ __ ] and having fun but I think
like penalizing people for being eager
it's not a right thing to do
alright let's go to another question so
Marius Chawla asks this is such a common
question what are the top three things a
start-up must achieve before VC firms or
say an angel investor would line up to
fund them there's a huge range of
answers to that if I were to rank things
in a hierarchy I think the single
biggest thing and this is going to be
obvious and we'll sort of work down the
hierarchy the single biggest thing would
be to have a high margin rapidly-growing
high traction product in other words
you're growing thirty percent
month-over-month you have 90 percent
margins and everybody's buying it mm-hmm
you have big brands buying a you have
small brands buying it or if it's a
consumer product it's just you know
scaling like crazy with extremely high
retention and spread and so the number
one thing is traction the second best
thing to have is
a product in a interesting or exciting
or hot market that people want to fund
or get involved with cryptocurrencies is
one area that's like that right now
where all sorts of things are getting
funded simply because it's in the crypto
market versus because it's good third
thing would be great team and then last
thing is none of those but a compelling
story yeah so that's sort of the
hierarchy now the thing is that in
Silicon Valley there's different or in
general there's different trends so
people get excited about a specific area
they'll fund anything in the area
whether as traction or not you know
similarly there may be teams or
individuals that are very well regarded
and they'll just get funded no matter
what and so I you know sometimes you
just need one of those things and it's
good enough yeah and sometimes I I mean
I think PG they've talked about Airbnb
is like cockroaches like just stayin
alive because I assume the question is
about like getting your first funding
but if it's not about that just reaching
profitability and being able to stay
alive makes you much more attractive to
a company because that's how you that's
how you generate leverage yeah cuz I
don't know often times I've talked to a
Michael Seibel who's written a lot about
this companies come to him and they're
like oh we need to raise a Series A
right now mm-hmm and unfortunately they
have no leverage anymore yeah I think a
tear point or to build on that point VC
funding isn't the only way to build a
business either like Oh bloom Berg is
you know tens of billions of dollar
company private company that is only
raised outside capital once and I think
is from Morgan Stanley like Morgan
Stanley or somebody bought I don't
remember what it was ten percent say or
fifteen percent of the company but he
basically bootstrapped it and I think
one of the things that people think
about too little is other sources of
funding it could be your customers just
paying you for a great product so that
you're profitable sometimes you can get
what are known as NR e's non-recurring
engineering charges where you charge
upfront to develop something for
somebody that you can then resell that
everybody else Microsoft actually used
to do this in the early days and they
similarly never had to raise funding
they took one round right before they
went public because of a relationship
but fundamentally they just bootstrapped
so I think too often people think that
they should be on the VC train when
really you know there's lots of
different ways to build a business
and sometimes those are actually much
better for founder's in terms of where
you end up oh definitely I think way too
few people think about what game they're
about to enter when they even just start
thinking about ideas because if you
think about ideas with the framework of
this has to be fundable in Silicon
Valley that like by nature constricts
your ideas and yet people people don't
consider what it means to be running a
thousand person company and what that
trickles down to in your life yeah or
you could be running a thousand person
company but you do without ever having
to raise external money totally yeah
which is great and I think the the value
judgments are the hard part because like
whatever whatever works for you that's
fine yeah all right let's go to another
question this on the first page my
company so Taylor before you asks my
company's at our early MVP stage what is
the best way to balance you know giving
our earliest customers great treatment
while also having Wallis of focusing on
growth yeah I'm gonna give to things
that are exactly opposite points of
advice the first point of advice is
really what you want to do is delight a
small number of customers with them
become your advocates and sort of scale
on top of you know that word-of-mouth it
really depends on what business you're
in and whether that's important or not
to the business it also depends on what
the product is what's going to prevent
growth or not can you automate some of
the things that are the six star service
how long will it take you to automate it
so it's a very actually there's a lot
behind that question the opposing piece
of advice is look if you have five
customers and you screw up it's
unfortunate and you should do what you
can to remedy it but it's only five
customers yeah so if you sort of screw
up as long as you don't anything truly
damaging to these people which you
shouldn't do you can recover because
your next 10,000 customers the ones that
you know that are going to matter so you
should you should be willing to
experiment and try things and fail at
things and you know Reed Hoffman used to
have this great quote that if you aren't
embarrassed by your first product you
waited too long to launch it yeah now he
qualifies that depending on what you're
building and everything else but I think
that's a great quote in terms of you
know often people wait too long to
launch versus launching too soon and so
it's okay to give yourself permission to
screw up a little yeah I think it's too
easy especially for people who are you
know
compelled to be makers to get attached
to your solution to the problem when in
reality it's about solving the problem
the only place where I'd qualify that is
if you're doing something in healthcare
where you know you don't want to sort of
move fast and break things if you're
building a pacemaker yeah you know so if
you're actually again this is back to
the if you're actually gonna hurt
somebody you shouldn't do it right but
if it's you know a SAS product that is
around a customer support tool maybe
it's okay if it if it doesn't quite work
perfectly the first time you should just
be transparent with your customers that
it's a new product and it's buggy again
or iterating yeah but it's not cute if
the wheels on your autonomous car fall
exactly yeah
related to that there's a question about
hiring from 10 may condo wall they ask
when you're sprinting in growth stage
how do you predict the engineers
required and hire accordingly
yeah there's sort of two things I think
the general philosophy should be things
should always feel tight yeah so you
should never feel like hey I have too
many people you should always feel like
you have too few people so in general if
you start to feel like hey there's a lot
of people showing up and not enough to
do then you've definitely screwed up
from a planning process perspective and
this is actually something that the high
growth handbook touches on with Claire
who's Johnson and the conversation with
her is there are a set of simple
planning processes that you can undergo
where you basically start to ask where
do I want to build over what time frame
how many people do I need to actually do
it what's the relative priorities of
these things and therefore you come up
with a hiring plan and usually that
hiring plan isn't staggered over the
course of a year and so even when you're
very early on and you're three people or
four people and you have to build a
bunch of stuff if you've just been
funded I would advocate that going into
the fundraise you actually have that
hiring plan because it tells you what
your burn is gonna be it tells you how
much money you actually need to raise I
think too often founders just say oh I'm
gonna raise I'm making up a number two
million dollars when maybe they should
raise three or maybe they should raise
less but you know the number feels very
arbitrary versus having an underlying
plan which says this is where we're
gonna spend money this is how we're
gonna spend it this is how long it'll
last us actually think that's a very
useful exercise for anybody to go
through and it also then informs what
you're actually going to build which is
just like basic business fundamentals
yeah but very very view
surprisingly few people do it like I'm
aware yeah I'm around it because it's
like raising money has been turned into
this game that people want to win and
that in and of itself feels like an end
to them but it's not yeah so alright we
have a couple more questions
TD Bryant the second asked question when
your organization is experiencing
exponential growth how do you choose
which functions to outsource of versus
build you know hire someone a picture it
depends on what what you're actually
building so okay you know Instagram for
example famously had I think about it
dozen employees when they were acquired
by Facebook
and so they actually kept the team
really lean because at the time they
hadn't quite gone into the phase of
monetizing the product building out ads
building out a bunch of other stuff and
so they really just kept it to
engineering and you know maybe one or
two other functions so it depends a
little bit on your objective as a
company do you want to sell do you want
to build out the whole thing etc if your
focus is on you know going for it then
there's a few functions that you're
gonna add and it really depends on the
type of business your and when you add
them so there's an earlier question
around when should you add somebody as a
general counsel or a compliance person
if you're in a highly regulated industry
you may want to add that person quite
early in the first ten people or the
first 50 people but if you're not in a
highly regulated industry maybe you
don't add a GC until you're much larger
and so I think it really depends a bit
when all is said it done you know I
can't think of very many functions that
you want to outsource I think there are
aspects of functions that you want
outsourced so for example on the benefit
side you're not going to come up with
your own benefits plans right you're
gonna go and you're gonna work with
somebody and they're gonna say here's
your insurance policy and your 401k and
all the stuff it's like a framework you
used to invest right in terms of what
are the things you personally
yeah like stripe or new zenefits or
whatever yeah I view that less is
outsourcing functions unless I'm
misunderstanding the question and more
about outsourcing pieces of
infrastructure that everybody keeps
building and my mind function means HR
or engineering or product or you know
the functional org if what you're asking
is like what pieces of my IT stack I
should or you know of my stack I should
that's worse than yeah I mean I would
definitely try and use other party
services for payments or for other
things simply because it's really
onerous to rebuild those from scratch
yeah I think again this maker mindset
causes people to feel like they should
innovate everything and you don't have
to innovate yeah yeah there's actually a
great I think I carries a blog post or
podcasts on the end recent site where
they talked about how technical founders
always want to reinvent sales and you
know there's a way to do sales it's
worked for you know tens of years and
you don't need to necessarily hire
technical people for every role and you
don't need to hire you know a PhD in
engineering for sales unless you know
it's a very very technical sale yeah I
see it too but like companies getting
really creative with how like their
shares are issued or equity or whatever
it's like dude stop yeah the things that
are important to the company and its
survival and things that really don't
matter and sometimes it's okay to do the
things that don't matter because it's
fun and it keeps the job interesting and
exciting and sometimes it's just always
the time yeah agreed
all right so I want to get to the Dragon
Ball Z question juice I think that's
like obviously the most pressing and
important one button here all right and
roopa cool asks who is your favorite
dragon ball z /g t / super villain and
this is based on your avatar on twitter
yeah that's right so Goku is my avatar
Twitter you know lately I'd say and this
is still an old anime slash manga I'm
more of a Naruto person and really what
I would have wanted to have is Itachi
Uchiha as my avatar but it was just a
little bit too gruesome for Twitter and
obviously as well he's a very
misunderstood character in terms of
really always focused on trying to do
the right thing but then sort of taking
the fall for the hidden leaf village and
everything else by joining the Akatsuki
so you know I just thought that I'd keep
it simple and have Goku and if people
have any good anime or manga suggestions
please just hit me up on Twitter right
on if people want to reach out to you if
they want to buy the book where should
they go yeah for the book the best place
is Amazon right now it says that the
it's temporarily out of stock you can
ignore that it just means that there's a
bunch of books at straight paths that
are just sort of piled up waiting to
processed or that are being shipped over
so you can still just order and they'll
show up within a week or two and your
website is allowed Gale calm correct
cool all right thanks man Jonathan shot
me
you